we have a lot of project examples so
these project examples are from
well-digested publications uh
highly peer-reviewed publications and uh
our team is capable of taking
publications so for example if a faculty
if if i have a publication
and it in involves bioinformatics
methods and i would want to teach uh
using that application to my class so
our team is capable of converting those
publications into these research
projects that could be integrated into
the curriculum utilizing the the server
or utilizing some of the tools that
could be uh helpful in developing a
project for educational purpose so these
are educational projects about different
topics from precision medicine to
infectious diseases to population health
to biotechnology and agriculture space
and astrobiology so these are available
on omics logic learn for students to
take that step two so the step one is to
learn about the very basics develop
understanding about each of this
each of these
keywords first and then understand that
how the data analysis is done and using
some of the example data sets and then
go to some advanced data sets
and develop some specialization in some
of these areas so followed by that uh we
have a group of mentors who are
available to help students progress
through these different steps
of
taking from
basic learning
to learning about how do you access all
of these resources and then how do you
manage your time and then what is the
outcome that you are actually going to
get based on your efforts so all of
these are done through
through our support team and also
through our mentors and through all
these resources that i've showed you
just now so uh doing these basic
coursework is very important for anyone
to do go for specialization so in
specialization we also have like very
specialized courseworks course work uh
which is designed for groups such as uh
the namuchi group that you saw so the
naguchi group is have an infectious
disease
agenda they are working on different
infectious diseases and they want to uh
incorporate a lot of omics research into
that uh into their into their um into
their research so we collaborated with
them first for this infectious disease
program where we help the student and
the phd students and also master
students to uh to in incorporate
high-end bioinformatics to their studies
so that
the study is more robust and more
complete with uh taking advantage of big
data and the data that is available
on public repositories and the data they
have generated so obviously the impact
of that study is going to enhance a lot
and you kind of integrate and understand
different types of uh
data to
think about a system biology or a
holistic approach for a certain problem
so that is something
for specialization coursework curriculum
that we have and my team is here on uh
so they will be able to help share about
these specialization course tracks and
uh the suggestions we have designed and
the curriculums that we have designed
for such posts work so similarly we have
course work on precision medicine we
have course work on uh we have we have
project work on omix and agribiology and
uh we will be happy to uh collaborate
with some of the agricultural institute
and uh um and complete this uh
specialization track uh similarly we
recently started omics spaceomics and
there will be a lot of a lot of experts
from the industry and from the academic
uh areas coming and talking about
spaceomics and also helping uh students
uh learn about the area where this space
uh where space omix is uh is utilized so
it's a space comics is dedicated to the
study of homies data to study molecular
mechanisms affected by space travel and
which is critical for astronomers
astronauts health so
along with that along with not just
omics but also
[Music]
kami informatics and drug discovery we
are going to uh show we are going to uh
um come up with this summer program
in in april where we are going to
discuss the application of game
informatics and drug discovery and also
understand from a
standpoint of how do you interpret and
analyze three-dimensional structure
three-dimensional data from biomedical
uh research from uh from the public
repository in similar lines to what we
are doing with uh with our other data
types so combining all of this uh now
just i'll just want to take you
back there how do you know which program
is coming when so we have a schedule uh
page so it's an event page that we have
put together so i'll uh our team will be
sharing this page so in this page you
will see that the number of events that
we are doing in march we did a lot of
events including this one uh the faculty
mentor workshop we have the logic
symposium coming up and also in march uh
uh we uh we are going to conclude with
uh post representation and all of that
for a student in april we have these
programs coming up introduction to
bioinformatics chem informatics so you
can check this out we keep on updating
this page to sh to see uh the training
programs that we have planned throughout
the summer many of these programs will
be available so uh along with these
training programs uh the component of
doing a research work or project work is
something that i wanted to cover in this
presentation so uh as as as
we are discussing about these different
type of technologies followed by these
technologies uh how do we apply these
technologies on a real data set and real
problem so uh we have this program
called research fellowship or indus and
industry internship so a research
fellowship is where you are trying to
work on your on a research problem where
the faculties are also
providing us with their research problem
what uh what their students could work
on
in the in a university system so we
recently collaborated with amit
university uh where we collaborated for
uh faculty development and also we
collaborated for research projects and
uh training of students and uh working
with
a group of students who would work on
faculty projects and develop those
faculty projects for commercialization
for also um
for also like grant and publications and
all of that so through the internship
program uh with the faculty uh of a
university uh this is possible and that
is what we have created uh for
universities as a program where we are
taking this step one step two step three
step four uh from a cohort uh where we
are starting a program uh about the
partnership program which is just about
the basic which is free and then the
hands-on and the guided programs where
you have all these examples and all
these uh all these data sets to explore
and develop those those skill sets to be
able to work on a research project so to
be able to work on a research project
it's called the summer research
fellowship the summer research
fellowship is coming up in this summer
but this research fellowship program is
available to students to develop
projects on of their own uh and using
these all these types of uh analysis
methods so after completing the training
student can develop independent project
proposals identify existing group
projects on or collaborate and find
internship around the omics logic cohort
so along with the faculty projects that
the faculty can propose uh in
collaboration with the pine biotech
mentors uh there are other opportunities
for students as well so bioinformatics
does play a critical role in modern drug
discovery so we are working on projects
such as uh drug repurposing biomarker
screening and design of personalized
treatment regimes so as a result many
industry and research labs are seeking
out experts that are knowledgeable in
homeless data processing analysis and
integration some of these skill sets are
really really important for students who
are seeking uh jobs and internships and
career in this a in this field so we
have already discussed some of these
outcomes based on the number of hours
that the students are able to give the
number of hours that a trainer is able
to give and also like uh the time uh
timeline of the internships so this
internship program and also like
designing a bioinformatics project we
have already have the coursework for
anyone to learn about these different
steps uh after learning about the
coursework like how do we do look for
research topics we have recorded videos
for all of these steps uh and also data
sets that we have
working on with different students and
are published and showcased in different
poster competitions in in around the
globe
and getting recognition so for students
it's a great opportunity
because not only through linkedin but
also through different uh uh
different challenges different
symposiums different uh workshops uh
getting recognition and winning uh those
events and also getting uh positions uh
abroad which are fully funded so these
are some of the opportunities that we
saw with uh some of the students such as
ujja she's doing a fully funded phd
based on the research she did and
proposed uh in germany now after
finishing her master's similarly the
lara is working who worked on a uh space
project were able to publish this
project and now working on as a space so
mix mentor and we also have high school
students who've been able to do the same
using some of these automatic resources
and also coming up with projects that
they thought would be helpful as a
citizen scientist
providing them with the right resources
we saw that there is a huge interest in
high school students and uh huge
potential as well
so uh these courses as i said like are
decided on the basis of the interest of
the faculty and also the administration
some universities are looking for
courses in
data science and machine learning and
how do you apply and some some of the
universities are looking at very
specialized courses and all of them do
begin with the basic
basic course work that is to integrate
and bridge the gap that we see in
bioinformatics curriculum that has been
taught for years and years where we are
trying to go through the uh
go through the content which is rapidly
changing and evolving in this period in
this era so that is one of the reasons
that we have come up with all of these
curriculums so that it integrates with
the university curriculum and so that
students get an opportunity to learn
about the scientific research that is
ongoing and get relevant opportunity in
the industry so uh obviously to learn
about all of this you need to learn and
start at an early stage that helps you
develop all these skill sets and
understand about this different type of
data and also to be able to come up with
a project with uh with good outcomes so
to help with that this we not only have
academic patients but also industry
leaders
who come up who comes uh time to time
and help students with job opportunities
and also career guidance
so um there are also opportunities for
students to become campus ambassadors
and uh represent these
opportunities to another group of
students so
with this i would like to
i would like to ask uh if there are any
questions that uh if if you think that
any of this is interesting and i would
be really appreciate i would really
appreciate if there's any feedback uh
from from the from the participants
[Music]
between computation tool and the
bioinformatics tool
i don't understand the difference
difference between computational tool
and
bioinformatics tool
so a computational tool which uh which a
computational tool can be any tool that
uses computational
power to help in some sort of to
analysis so a computational tool that
you are using could be a word processor
is a computational tool but when we are
talking in the context of bioinformatics
then we are talking about a tool that
can analyze biological data a tool that
can help in
the biological data so the kind of data
changes and obviously with that the
specialization changes and so some of
these computational tools which are used
for day-to-day life and for other
activities uh varies from the
biotechnology or bioinformatics tool
that is developed by the scientific
community who are working for ages now
okay thank you sir
thank you sir
okay thank you and dr alvarez and if
there are any more questions i will be
happy to answer
and uh
some of the resources uh i'm gonna i'm
gonna go back to some of the pages
that are we have prepared so as i saw as
i showed you already so this is the
research collaborative
omics logic
page for research projects that we have
prepared this has all the links and
pipelines that we have created for the
universities so our collaborative
universities such as amity university
what we have been able to do is that we
have created a pipeline starting from a
basic training getting registered to
completing the basic modules that i
showed you completing the intermediate
coursework and then certification and
giving a qualification and examination
and then doing the research fellowship
and getting some of these pi outcomes so
you can see that there are many students
who've been able to complete and go
through this entire funnel and pipeline
and come up with research projects which
we were able to publish on our portal
and also elsewhere so this entire
journey starts with uh
starts with collaboration with
universities and also we get to
visit the universities meet them in
person students and help so similarly
from the university there's an
administrator there's a professor and a
student who helps in coordinating all of
that and collaborating for uh for some
of these outcomes that we achieve from
these these collaborations so this is
about the university who are utilizing
our programs and also for people who are
interested in research a different type
of research we have this page called
research topics so here what we have
done is what we put together is like
what kind of research that you can
do for infectious disease bioinformatics
so some of these are listed out not all
of them obviously but uh we have put
together a different omics
application and also for different areas
of research that we are working with our
students that we are working with some
of the faculties are put together here
and with some examples obviously and
with some sessions from experts that uh
that have helped uh students to learn
about these uh different technologies so
this is another page that i wanted to
show you all uh and then we have this uh
for those who would want to
not do it themselves but provide give it
to the experts to do the some of the
work so if you want to integrate omix
data analysis into your own research you
can collaborate through uh our server
services so you can uh you can let us do
the work that you would want in your
publication or in your research project
and we have this omix logic service for
that where we have uh licensing for
different types of research that you
would want to do which is a monthly
license and also we have these different
uh
sample based analysis options that are
available which are as a service that
you can take and we will provide you
with the report and all the details of
that with all the details of analysis
that we do for a specific project so
this this works out when uh before that
we have several discussion and we
finalize and we scope the
the scope the
uh project and the objectives so then we
have the chemi informatics program the
the uh
topics you can take
and the curriculum you can take a look
here it's a basic program on chemi
informatics and
structural biology following following
with that we will have another program
which will be more about ai machine
learning and using structure biology for
uh drug discovery uh to a more detailed
uh
aspect in the in the late summer and
then i wanted to also show you i've
already shown you this and uh the
courses and the research symposium so we
have an amazing event coming up and i
really appreciate if uh many of you
could join this event so there are a lot
of sessions that would be uh about uh
different technologies and what we've
been able to work and with different uh
partners so uh we have a session about
asia and then we have sessions from
university partners in india and also we
have session about the research
fellowship program and also poster
competition and then we have the african
uh
uh participants are going to talk about
uh the programs there and the university
in africa and the uh and the industry in
africa talking about the challenges and
also the ongoing work in bioinformatics
in africa then we have the us panel
starting with mr liabrotsky our ceo and
then we have uh uh sessions from experts
uh from the us uh from reputed
universities such as georgetown
university and professor sunawasudevan
then google talking about their
strategic programs and uh
cloud technology and then we have uh
then we have dr adelaide rhodes where
she will be talking about
bioinformatics as a career option and
addressing all of those so many
questions could be answered we have a
panel for latin america followed by that
there will be a discussion then on the
day two we have the uh we have the
industry from india we have the industry
from uh from europe uh we have the
[Music]
we have uh in from the us we are talking
about lab and future and women in stem
uh from pistola alliance where there's a
group of
group of uh organizations uh working on
different aspects then we have a
specialized uh session by tower research
in in banff tower biometrics research
center where these uh experts are going
to come and talk about very specific
topics
uh covering single cell transcriptomics
data analysis and then uh
how do we work with uh and customize
pipelines and then there are 16 s rrna
meta taxonomy and then many for learning
so it will be an enthralling experience
for all of us who will be attending this
session and i'll be really glad if you
can also make it it's a free for
listener and it also gives an
opportunity for students to be a part of
this and also uh get certification uh at
the end of this so we have space omix as
i was telling you that a lot of experts
coming from nasa and elsewhere to talk
about uh space omix and also there will
be price distribution ceremony for
students who get
the
prizes for best poster and then we have
the us panel discussion where we were
discussing about the nippy national
association of idea principal
investigators and the nih grants and all
of the work that is going on uh to help
uh
to help integrate data science and
bioinformatics in u.s uh through the nih
grants so this will be a great
experience so i would encourage all of
you to join so this is it from my